what is dilemma dilemma is something
that
I can't believe I didn't know the value
of dilemma when I was an executive
I cannot believe in all the scripts I
analyzed over 12 and a half years that I
didn't have it turned I think I Loosely
understood dilemma in terms of story and
conflict however I it wasn't until after
I left the studio
and dived into story in every way
imaginable that the word dilemma came
into my realm I understood dilemma
through a structuralist Jeff Kitchen
yes that that I first took one of my
very first structure courses from when I
became an executive
and when I left the studio
I re-looked at what I learned from
Jeffrey kitchen and dilemma
somehow just came to me in this way that
changed how I see story and and that
became everything for developing my
brand and looking at the value of
dilemma I feel like so many story people
skip over or don't Define dilemma and
dilemma is everything to setting up a
story when we feel how the character is
caught between a rock and a hard place
and we for me I think the aha moment
that went beyond what I learned from
Jeff was the recognition
that the choice the character makes in
the Dilemma is what defines the external
Pursuit so that was my big aha moment
that helped me I I think there's so much
that we learn from everybody who's
studying story I've been analyzing story
for 30 years now and when I look at my
counterparts who think in alignment like
Jeffrey kitchen like Michael Hague like
John York they're they're when you have
people wear Dara marks that are seeing
story in a similar way and you kind of
look at like what is their terminology
versus my terminology and what what is
aligning and what is missing and how do
you redefine something so that the
writer can grasp it more
is dilemma the same as problem
dilemma I feel like is something that
everyone in life understands because we
all face dilemmas continuously
so I think the difference between a
dilemma and a problem a problem is more
of like an obstacle
versus a dilemma is creating a Pursuit
so a problem or obstacle is more
something that happens to a character on
the way to a goal versus a dilemma is a
trigger event that was another thing
that I added to dilemma was the
recognition that a trigger event happens
to the character before they face the
Dilemma so that was something that was
missing and what I understood of it
before as well and that was something
that I was like ah that's what was
missing so when there's a trigger event
that leads a character to a dilemma then
the the choice that they make in that
dilemma defines a Pursuit so that's what
differentiates a dilemma from a problem
and some of that is is set up before the
actual the story starts because it's a
childhood wound yes yes I have come to
find in the way I teach and see story
that the stories that are hitting at the
highest level uh are stories where it's
almost like a math equation it's it's
almost like you're looking at the
trigger event that happens in childhood
then you're often looking at a trigger
event that happens before we enter the
story and then the inciting incident or
series trigger and dilemma in TV will
split open those two wounds and then
you're developing the character from
those three places as a way to add depth
to the character
how does a character's backstory
influence their goals and their dilemmas
when you look at in life and we think
about like I think a TV show that I feel
like uh perfected the idea I think when
loss first started and it looked at
memories in our life it looked at
because the way that loss developed
characters at first was the idea of
going back to a specific moment in a
person's life and kind of arcing that
out and then when I think about the way
it evolved was a recognition that the
flashback sequence was recognizing that
it isn't Just One Moment In The Arc of
that moment that influences our choices
in the present it is a series of moments
from different life traumas or Joys or
failures that inform choice so by going
to different life places then then we
feel what is influencing why the
character is choosing the way they are
how do past wounds hold a character back
I like to think that when you look at
the past wound uh you're looking at
starting with the childhood wound you're
looking at something called a negative
narrative that we can all identify with
the voices we hear in our head that tell
us I'm not enough I'm not good enough
I'm not worthy of this that starts with
the childhood wound and then progresses
from that negative narrative in the mind
that goes into a flaw and when you go
into the flaw the flaw is what's holding
a character back and again we all
identify with flawed Behavior we all
have flaws and and we all become
conscious of our flaws does not mean we
heal our flaws we become conscious and
story is the opportunity for the
character to become conscious of that
flaw and decide if they want to
acknowledge the flaw or if they want to
resist working or processing through
that flaw in order to get to the goal
have you seen it where writers make
their characters too perfect or too
flawed
both yes both I
I feel the the um
the characters that are too perfect are
characters that we can't identify with
by characters it used to be that when
you read scripts and you would read a
character description you would read oh
she's beautiful or he's handsome and it
started
sounding like rubber like you you can't
tell anything about a character from
that uh description and I think writers
have gotten to a place where they
recognize the value of describing a
personality trait is going to bring you
much deeper into that character and
understanding that character
how many dilemmas should a main
character face
in this story there are two pivotal
places for the Dilemma the two pivotal
places
are in the inciting incident setup or in
the climax
the value of having a dilemma in both
places is a tremendous value because it
shows you
is the character going to transform or
not when you look at the the structure
that I've seen shows and films do where
you have the character often facing a
similar dilemma in the climax that they
faced in the inciting incident then the
question becomes did they learn through
going through action obstacles and and
Stakes did they learn what the flaw was
that was holding them back and through
that recognition are they able to move
forward so if the writer puts a dilemma
in the opening and the climax as well as
setting up if you're doing streaming
setting up what's coming next as a
cliffhanger then there those are are
three places that there is tremendous
value in using a dilemma but the opening
and the climax are great places for the
Dilemma
how much does the viewer really want the
character to change I mean in real life
most people don't really change that
much yeah you know they might work on
themselves but we're still kind of all
who we were at seven years old so how
how much do we really want to see our
favorite characters evolve
it is a great question
in film the transformation
is everything
because we want to know that the
character evolved from how they thought
in the beginning to how they think in
the end and there's something that with
the format of the beginning mental end
that fulfills us if we can feel that
transformation versus
in say like when you look at The
Sopranos and people would say well Tony
Soprano is never going to change so I
think that's where it comes to Advanced
writing when you recognize all right
there are certain parts of a person that
won't change however within the conflict
involved in each story you do want to
feel like the character is taking a step
of
awareness that is causing even a slight
change it's not going to change the
character trait of the dominant flaw
however the awareness
has a universal effect for the audience
to become aware of what is holding them
back and when you see a character who
can move through that block then it
helps the audience to think if they can
do it I can do it
well I haven't watched the second season
of White Lotus but yes I don't know if I
really want to see Jennifer coolidge's
character change too much I like the way
she is yeah because I enjoy watching
she's kind of a lovable hot mess yeah
and I don't know if I want her to become
perfect you know in season two she's a
lovable hot mess oh good okay okay oh
yes that's very well put in that
description she is a lovable hot mess in
season two she I feel like Mike White is
very authentic to the recognition of
what the strengths of that character is
and plays into that season two is
brilliant oh great I'm looking forward
to watching you like season one you are
going to love season two